configuring the Android emulator is easy
with the AVD wizard in android studio
it offers default settings for optimal
emulator performance if you want to
double-check your a VDS are configured
correctly and your machine can run them
with full hardware acceleration follow
these few steps first of all check that
your CPU supports the required
virtualization extensions on Windows and
Mac only intel vt-x is supported and the
necessary virtualization software from
Intel is available through the SDK
manager inside Android studio on some
machines VTX is disabled by default in
that case please refer to your
motherboard or laptop manual on how to
enable it if you're using Linux both the
intel vt-x and AMD v virtualization
technologies are supported through k vm
in our documentation pages link below we
provide information on how to check if k
vm is installed in your system now that
we have the most difficult part out of
the way let's go through the AVD
creation process on the first screen
select the device skin that you'd like
to use for development if you don't have
a high end GPU you might benefit from
choosing a device with a lower
resolution you can always change the
size later by editing the AVD
next choose the system image there are
three important guidelines for this step
choose one of the more recent releases
with a higher API level number as those
contain the newest fixes and
optimizations make sure you're selecting
an x86 image and also one marked as
having Google api's which means you'll
be able to test apps that make use of
Google Play services or integrate with
some core apps such as Google Maps on
the last step you can select from
different graphics acceleration modes
but leaving it on auto should detect
your GPU capabilities and select the
best mode to run if you're having
problems it's best to always make sure
that your graphics drivers are up to
date you can read more about the various
GPU settings in our documentation also
linked in the description if you
encounter any bugs when running the
emulator please read the Android studio
bug finding process and report them
using the issue tracker
thanks for watching and if you want to
learn more about Android studio and
Android development click on one of the
videos here